hi and welcome to this fifth lecture on
this course in on reinforcement learning
my name is adavan hasselt and today i
will be talking to you about model free
prediction
there's a lot of background material on
this slide and this is a fairly long
lecture
you don't have to worry about reading
all of this at once
the most important chapters for this
lecture are chapters five and six
and we will cover some material from
these other chapters as well
but
some of that will be shared with the
subsequent lectures so this is actually
background material for a couple of
lectures in a row
we will just not exactly go through
these in exactly the same sequence as
the book does this is why we list a
fairly large chunk of background
material here
feel free to defer some of that reading
until later in fact it might help the
understanding to go through the material
not all at once but to revisit it later
also don't forget to pause during the
lecture i mean sometimes i will ask you
a question ask you to think about
something and of course that's a good
occasion to actually pause for a second
and actually reflect maybe write some
stuff down but also like i said this is
a fairly long lecture so feel free to
make use of the fact that this is a
recording and therefore you can pause
and maybe even take a break or maybe
even consume the lecture over more than
one day if that's uh works for you i do
encourage you to
not wait too long between looking at
different parts of the lecture in order
not to forget the beginning when you get
to the end
first i'm just going to recap where we
are we're talking about reinforcement
learning which we defined as being the
science of learning how to make
decisions in which there's an agent
interacting with an environment
and the agent takes actions and the
environment
will be observed by the agent
and then internally in the agent we will
have a policy a value function and or a
model
where in any case we should have a
policy because the agent should pick its
actions somehow
and the general problem involves taking
into account time and consequences
because these actions can change not
just the immediate reward but also the
agent's state and also the environment
state which means that subsequent
rewards might be affected by actions
that you've taken that you've taken
earlier
to recap a little bit where we are in
the course right now in these last two
lectures we've seen
planning by dynamic programming diana
told you a lot about this which is all
about using computation to solve a known
problem so we have a markov decision
process or a model if you want to call
it that and then dynamic programming is
a mechanism to
be able to infer
accurate predictions or optimal policies
for such a problem
this and in the subsequent lectures
we're basically going to relax this
assumption that you have access to this
true model and instead we're going to
use
sampling so we're going to use
interaction with the world and we call
that model-free and at first we'll talk
about model-free prediction in this
lecture which is the process to estimate
values when you do not have the markov
decision process you don't know what it
is but you can interact with it this of
course is the case when you're for
instance in the real world you could
imagine that the world maybe has some
sort of a really large markov decision
process underneath it but you don't have
immediate access to that so instead all
that you can do is interact
for after model 3 prediction we can talk
about model frequent control which is
the process to optimize values rather
than estimating them so please keep in
mind that this lecture is about
estimating so we're not going to talk
about policies
much
and then we will also talk a little bit
about function approximation and some
deep reinforcement learning in this
lecture and then a little bit more in
subsequent lectures
and especially deep reinforcement
learning will be deferred
quite a bit we'll briefly touch upon it
finally we will also talk in these
upcoming lectures on about off policy
learning which is also
a prediction task but this is
this term refers to making predictions
about a policy different from the one
that you're following
more on that to follow later
also in later lectures we will talk
about model-based learning and planning
policy gradients and ectocritic systems
and of course more deep reinforcement
learning
finally we will cover some advanced
topics and current research but only
much later
okay so let's get started
our first topic will be monte carlo
algorithms and i'll explain in a moment
what that means
so
the point here is to use sampling we're
going to interact with the world and
this will allow us to learn without a
model
if we're sampling complete episodes in
reinforcement learning we call this
monte carlo so that's a specific usage
of the term monte carlo sampling is also
used to refer to other things in machine
learning in general
in reinforcement learning when people
say monte carlo they typically mean
sample complete episodes
an episode is a trajectory of experience
which has some sort of a natural ending
point beyond which you're not trying to
predict any further we'll see examples
of that in a moment
this is a model free approach because
you don't need any knowledge of the
markov decision process you only need
interaction or samples
to make that concrete
let's start with a simple example that
we've actually seen before in lecture
two the multi arm bandit
so in the multi-arm bandit we have a
bunch of actions and we're trying to in
this case just estimate the action
values in lecture two we talked about
optimizing these action values by
picking a smart exploration policy
for now we're just talking about
model-free predictions so for now we're
only interested in estimating these
action values so the true action value
here is given on the right hand side
which is the expected reward given an
action
and then the estimates at some time step
t
is
written somewhat verbosely here but it's
basically simply the average of the
rewards given that you've taken that
action on the subsequent time steps
and we can also update this
incrementally we also briefly discussed
this in lecture two where you have some
sort of a step size parameter alpha and
you add to the action value estimate
that you have right now so qt of 80 you
add the step size parameter times an
error term and this error term is simply
the reward that you've just
observed minus our current estimate
all the other action values stay
unchanged and then if you pick this step
size parameters to be exactly one over
the number of times you've selected that
action then this is exactly equivalent
to the flat average that is depicted
above
you may have noticed that there's a
slight change in notation we've now
moved to the notation that is more
common when we talk about sequential
decision processes so markov decision
processes and such
where we typically increment the time
step immediately after taking the action
in the banded literature it's more
conventional to
denote the reward as arriving at the
same time step as taking the action but
in reinforcement learning in a more
general case we typically increment the
time step immediately after the action
which basically means we
interpret the reward to arrive at the
same time as your next observation
that's just a small notational note to
avoid confusion between this lecture and
the earlier lecture on bandits
now we're going to extend slightly to
make this more general and we're going
to consider bandits with states
for now the episodes will still remain
to be one step long as in the bandit
case before
and this means that actions do not
affect the state transitions
which means that if you take an action
you will receive some reward and then
you will see a new state but this this
new state actually doesn't depend on
your action so there are now potentially
multiple different states so that's a
difference from before
but they don't depend on your actions
and that means that there's no long-term
consequences to take into account
and then the goal is to estimate the
expected reward condition not just on
action but also on the state so this is
in some sense a slight extension from
the
normal banded case that we discussed
before
and these are called contextual bandits
in the literature where the state is
then often called a context
so state and context in that sense are
interchangeable terms
now we're going to do basically
make an orthogonal step in this lecture
and we're going to talk about function
approximation a little bit and then
we're going to return back to these
bandits with states and talk about how
these things are related before we then
go to the sequential case
so we're talking about value function
approximation to be more precise so far
we've mostly considered lookup tables
where every state has its own entry
or every state action pair has its own
entry so think of this as a big table
stored on your uh
in the robot's brain or in the agent's
brain and for every state and action you
might see you just have a separate entry
that you might update
but of course this comes with some
problems because there might be way too
many states and their actions to
actually store this effectively in
memory but even if you could store this
in memory that might not be the best
idea because it might be way too slow to
learn the value of each state if you're
going to do that completely
independently and individually
in addition individual states are
actually not often fully observable
if you talk about these environment
states at least
so so far i've just set state i didn't
actually say specifically what i meant
with state i'll talk about that more in
a moment
but in the simplest
case you could consider that the food
the environment state is fully
observable
so that the observation maybe is the
environment state and then you could
also use that same state as your agent
state in that case the aging state the
observation and the environment say it
could all be the same but even if that's
the case then it could be very large but
of course often it's also not the case
now you could still have a finite agent
state and maybe store these separately
but then you still suffer from this
other problem that might be very slow if
you have many different agent states
so our solution for those problems is to
use function approximation
so we write vw or qw where w is now some
sort of a parameter vector and we're
going to update these parameters instead
of updating cells in this in a big table
so the parameter vector w will be
updated using monte carlo or temporary
difference learning which are two
algorithms that we're going to talk
about in this lecture
and the idea would be that we can
hopefully then generalize to unseen
states because this function should be
defined everywhere and the idea is that
if you pick a suitable function then if
you update a certain
state value in some sense you update
your parameters that are associated to
that state that then the values of
similar states would also automatically
be updated for instance you could have
you would be in this state you could
identify that states by looking at
certain characteristics certain features
and then you could update the values of
those features
and then maybe if you reach a different
state which is different in some ways
but it shares a couple of those features
maybe we can make a meaningful
generalization and learn something about
its value before even visiting it
now here's a note first on states what
do i mean with states
so we're not going to necessarily assume
the environment state is fully
observable so i'm going to
just going to recall that there's an
agent state update function
which takes the previous agent state st
minus 1 the action at minus 1 and your
current observation ot
where the reward could be considered
part of that observation or t or we
could also spell that out explicitly and
we can write it as an input to this
agent update function
and then our subsequent agent states st
is just a function of these previous
inputs
we talked about this in the first
lecture you might recall
so henceforth we will use stu whenever
we write s rest to denote the agent
state
you can think of this as either some
just a bunch of numbers inside your
agent a vector
or in the simplest case it could also
simply be the observation
and indeed it could be as i mentioned
before that the environment states if
the environment is fully observable
is is observable in every step so that
the aging state could be equal to the
environment state but that's a special
assumption that won't be the case all
the time
so we're just going to talk about
agent states whenever we say state
for now we're not going to talk about
how to learn this agency the update
function as you can imagine this can be
quite important to have a good agency
update function sometimes you can hand
construct one sometimes maybe you're
much better off if you can learn this we
will cover that in later lectures but
for now we're just going to set that
aside and we're just going to assume we
have some sort of an agent update
function
if you
think that's easier to understand the
algorithms feel free to consider state
whenever you see this in one of the
equations just to be the observation for
simplicity
okay now we're going to talk about
linear function approximation there's a
couple of reasons for this first this
makes things a little bit more concrete
if we can talk about a specific function
class in addition there's things later
that we can say for the linear case that
we can't actually completely say for the
non-linear case it's easier to analyze
theoretically we won't do that yet for
now
but we will do that later and it's good
to have this special case in mind
so it's a useful useful special case in
which we have a linear function and
basically what we're going to assume is
we're going to have some fixed feature
vector
so note we already assumed that we have
some sort of a fixed agent state update
function so we're going to set that
aside where the states come from and in
fact now we're even going to set aside
states themselves and we're going to
just say well in addition to that we
have some sort of a feature mapping that
turns the state into a bunch of numbers
so it's just a vector with a bunch of
elements
and we're going to consider that for now
to be fixed later we might consider
learning it but for now it's just a
fixed mapping
we're also introducing a little bit of
shorthand where we simply write x t
whenever we mean the features of state
at time step t
please keep that in mind
for instance features could include the
distance of a robot from different
landmarks
or maybe some trends in the stock market
or maybe the ps and pawn configurations
in chess you can come up with these
features by hand sometimes or later we
will discuss ways to find them
automatically
then the linear function approximation
approach takes these features and simply
defines our value function to be the
inner product
or dot product between our parameter
vector w and the features at the time
step x
of the state s that we see
um probably unnecessary but um the slide
is also reminding you what the inner
product looks like it's just a sum over
the components and it's multiplying each
of the features with the associated
weight
now we can talk about how to update
those weights and for that we have to
pick some sort of an objective
in this lecture we're talking about
predictions our objective will be to
minimize this loss
which defines a squared distance between
our current estimates
in this case according to this linear
function and the true value function v
pi obviously we don't have v pi so we're
going to replace this with things that
we can use but for now keep this
objective in mind
if we could then compute stochastic
gradients for this objective this would
converge to a global optimum of this
loss function because this loss function
is as they say convex
and there's only one optimal solution
which will so this uniquely defines the
optimal uh parameter vector w
that does not mean that we can reduce
this loss all the way to zero it could
be that the features are
not good enough to be able to accurately
predict the value for every state
if we do stochastic gradient descent the
update rule is very simple
we first note that the gradient of our
value function with respect to our
parameters w
are is simply the features we see here
on the left hand side
so at time step t if we see state st the
gradient of our value function on that
state will simply be xt
and then our stochastic gradient update
if we would have the true value function
v pi would simply be
to add
this
term which is the step size parameter
alpha times the error term the
prediction error times the feature
vector
and we can use this to update this
parameter vector w on every step but of
course we have to replace v pi with
something that we can have because we
don't have e pi i'll get to that in a
moment
first i want to say that the table
lookup case that we've considered
for instance for the banded lecture
earlier
is a special case
we can enumerate all of the states of
course in order to store these in a in a
big table you need a finite amount of
state of
of states otherwise you can't store them
separately
and then we could consider the feature
vectors to simply be a one hot feature
that has zeros on almost all of the
components except on the component that
corresponds exactly to the state that we
see
so that means we have exactly as many
states as we have
sorry exactly as many feature components
as we have states and then we note that
this means that the value function
estimates
under the linear function approximation
would then simply pick out the weight
that corresponds to that state so that
means that the weight for that state
will essentially be your value estimate
for that state
okay now we're going to go
back to the reinforcement running case
so that was kind of like more generic
about function approximation and we're
going to go back to these monte cardo
algorithms basically continuing from
before
so note that we were dealing with
bandits with states
and now we're basically going to make q
a parametric function for instance a
neural network or a linear function and
we can going to use this squared loss
which we now also multiply by a half
that's just for convenience
and then we could consider the gradient
of this
so similar to before we're going to
update our parameters w
so our new parameters wt plus one will
be our previous parameters wt
minus a small step size times the
gradient of this loss we can then write
out the definition of the gradient of
that loss which we do
here on the second line
and then we note that this expectation
doesn't actually depend on our
parameters so we can just push the
gradient inside
we get this update which is our step
size times an error term reward minus
our current estimate times the gradient
of this action value
and then we can sample this to get a
stochastic gradient update as we saw
before
and the tabular case would just be a
special case which is indexes into the
corresponding cell for the state action
pair
so we basically just use the exact same
things that we've seen before for the
bandit with state setting
and we can use a stochastic gradient
updates to do the prediction
in these cases
this also works for very large state
spaces this is just regression you could
do linear regression you could do
nonlinear regress regression which
you've probably covered in previous
courses
so we won't go into a lot of detail on
that but it's a valid update and it will
converge to the right
estimates where these estimates are i'm
reminding you limited in the sense that
you can't actually expect all of your
values to be perfect because it might be
that your function class is just not
rich enough to actually get all of the
values completely accurate in every
state but this process will converge
under suitable assumptions to
the best parameter vector that you can
find
so again for linear functions we
basically now are going to extend the
action value approach also to linear
functions where we're going to assume
that we have features for each state
action pair
and then we can just multiply rate
parameter w with these features which
means that the gradient of our action
value function will simply be the
features for that saved action pair
which means that this stochastic
gradient descent update for our weights
will then look like this where we simply
replace the gradient with those features
so over the linear update this update
corresponds to a step size times your
prediction error times a feature vector
and for the non-linear update you have
very similarly your step size times your
prediction error times a gradient
and a lot of our next algorithms would
look exactly the same they will just
change
certain aspects of this for instance
here we're still considering the bandit
case we're just considering learning
expected rewards so there's no sequences
yet
and that's where we're going to go next
now we're going to consider sequential
decision problems
so we're still doing prediction our goal
is just to predict the value of a policy
in subsequent lectures where i will be
talking about control optimizing the
policy but for now we're sticking to
prediction
and now we're just going to sample
trajectories under our policy and of
course not shown here on the slide but
of course the probabilities of these
trajectories also depend on the
underlying dynamics under the underlying
markov decision process
then so maybe somewhat obviously we can
extend the banded approach to
full returns by simply just sampling a
full episode
and then constructing a return i'm
reminding you that a return is simply
the accumulation of rewards so we have
gt the return from time step t into the
future
as defined as the immediate reward rt
plus one and then the discounted next
reward rt plus two and so on and so on
until in this case the end of the
episode which arrives at sometimes the
big t which is in the future
a return will only stretch as far as the
episode and then after the episode is
done we imagine we will be
reinitialized in the states and we can
go through this whole process again
and then the expected return which is
our goal is defined as simply the
expectation of these returns
so similar to the bandit with state
setting we can sample this and we can
use this instead of the expected return
as a target in our updates
this algorithm that does that is called
monte carlo policy evaluation
and it's covered in chapter five from
such an ambardo
now i'm going to walk you through an
example to give you a little bit more of
intuition of how that algorithm works in
practice
this example is in the game of blackjack
and blackjack is a card game in which
the goal is to get more points than an
opponent called the dealer
we're going to go first and we're going
to try to accumulate as many points as
we can
but not more than 21. so if you get more
than 21 points you go bust as they say
and so therefore basically your your
goal is to get as close to 21
without going beyond it
to do so you're going to draw cards and
each of these cards is going to be worth
a certain amount of points the number of
cards are simply worth how however like
large the number is so a card with a
three or four is worth three or four
points
all of the picture cards the jack queen
and king are worth 10 points and the ace
is a special card it's worth either 11
points or you can pick it to be worth
one point this is useful for when you
draw a card and you go above 21 if you
then had an ace you can say ah no my ace
is now no longer worth 11 points now i'm
going to make it worth one point instead
and now you're below 21 again
we're going to
formalize this problem
in in the following way where we're
going to enumerate states or so we're
going to go for a tabular approach
and this state will consist of our
current sum and this current sum is the
sum of the cards you have so far and
this will be between 12 and 21 for
reasons that i'll explain in a moment
i've already said if you go beyond 21
you have already gone bust so then the
episode ends so that state is
unimportant
but we're going to start with any number
between 12 and 21
and in addition to that we can also see
the dealer's card so the dealers card
we're only seeing one of them the dealer
is going to play after you so they are
going to draw more cards after you're
done
but you can already see one of these
cards and this is informative to tell
you whether you maybe should continue or
not
and then
in addition to that we also have an
additional state variable which tells us
whether we have a usable ace which
basically just means do we have an ace
and can we make that a's worth 11
without going above 21.
so say you have 16 points let's say you
have an 8th and a 5
and let's say you then draw a 10. this
would bring you to 26 points which as i
explained to to make you go bust but
then you can say i know my ace is now
only worth one point and i'm back at 16
points and i can go again but the state
will have changed because now you no
longer have a user ways
in terms of the action space there's two
different actions you can do you can
either stick at which point it's now the
dealer's turn and they will resolve this
will then terminate your episode or you
can draw which means you just take
another card if you draw you can draw
again in the next step or you could
stick in the next step
when you stick the episode always
terminates and you get a plus one if
then the dealer doesn't get a higher sum
than you or if the dealer goes bust
which is also possible so if the dealer
goes above 21 they lose if they don't go
above 21 but they have fewer points than
you they also lose and you get plus one
if you happen to arrive at exactly the
same number
you get zero
but if the dealer manages to get more
points than you without going above 21
then you get minus one
if instead you draw
if you go above 21 and you didn't have a
usable ace you cannot avoid this from
happening then you get minus one and the
episode terminates immediately the
dealer has now won
otherwise you get zero and then the game
continues so you could draw again or you
could stick
as i mentioned you start with at least
12 points this is simply because if you
have fewer than 12 points you should
always draw more cards because you can
never go bust
and therefore if you say have 11 points
there is no card that could bring you
above 21 because even if you draw an ace
you could always choose it to be worth
one so you can always get more points so
you can basically think of this as a
process a stochastic process that brings
you to the initial state of your episode
note that the
state description here is slightly
partial observable because we're just
giving you a number so you don't
actually know what that consists of
and even knowing whether you have a
usable ace or not doesn't actually give
you all the information that you could
have because for instance you could have
two aces and then that will be hidden
from you so there's some slight partial
observability here but that turns out
not to be a big factor
then what we do is we run monte carlo
learning so we're going to generate a
whole bunch of episodes and we're going
to sample the returns for those episodes
for some fixed policy
and then we're going to generate these
plots and i'm going to explain these in
a second
which show your value estimates for that
policy
and then of course in later lectures we
can talk about oh how should we then
maybe improve our policy to do better
but this is a reasonable policy in which
i believe you draw if you have fewer
than 17 points and otherwise you stick
or it's something similar
um
and what's shown here's four plots and
i'll explain what these are first i want
to draw your attention to the bottom
right where we see what the axes are on
this plot
so one axis is which card the dealer is
showing which is either an ace or a two
or a three and one or a ten where we
merge all of the picture cards just into
a ten as well because they're all worth
10.
and on the other axis we see the current
sum that we have it's either 12 13 and 1
or 21.
these z-axis the height is basically the
estimated value we see it's always
between -1 and 1 this is because the
maximum reward you can get during an
episode is plus one at the end
or the lowest reward is minus one at the
end
all of the intermediate rewards if there
are any are always zero because if you
draw but you didn't go bust you just get
zero so the total return for each
episode is between minus one and one or
it's either minus one or zero or one
and now i want to draw your attention to
these plots and i wanna go i'm going to
ask you a couple of questions that you
can think about so feel free to pause
the video if you want to think about
these things and in particular i want to
draw your attention now to the top left
plot
the left column here corresponds to
having seen ten thousand episodes
the right column corresponds to having
seen half a million episodes
now the top row corresponds to having a
usable ace and the bottom row
corresponds to not having a usable a's
interstate
so the first question i want to ask you
is uh
why does this top left plot look so much
more bumpy than the plot to its right
and then the second question is why does
it look more bumpy than the plot below
it
so feel free to think about that for a
second and then i'm going to give you uh
my explanation
so maybe the first one was uh maybe
somewhat obvious so after 10 000
episodes we don't have a lot of data for
each of these states yet but after half
a million episodes we have accumulated
by now quite a bit of data for each of
these states so our value estimates have
improved
so maybe the difference between the left
and the right was somewhat obvious maybe
the difference between the top and the
bottom is a little bit less obvious but
the reason for that is i'm going to
argue that the states at the top in the
top row are actually less common than
the states in the bottom row
in a normal deck of cards
there's 52 cards out of which only four
are aces
so
states in which you have an ace are
actually comparatively rare so even on
the left we've seen 10 000 episodes in
total that doesn't mean that every state
has seen the same amount of episodes and
in fact the states in which you have an
ace may have been visited much less
often in some cases now finally i just
want to draw your attention to the shape
of the value function where we we see
maybe
somewhat expectedly that if your own sum
is high then the value function becomes
higher
and in fact if your sum is 21 then it's
quite close to plus one except if the
dealer is showing an ace because if the
dealer is showing an ace it's actually
not that unlikely that the dealer will
also get to 21 at which point your
return will be zero rather than plus
one okay so this is just an example of
monte carlo learning and how you could
use that to find the value of a policy
and maybe somewhat obviously we can then
later use this information to then
improve our policy but we won't go into
that
yet so what we've seen here is that
monte carlo algorithms can indeed be
used to learn value predictions
unfortunately when episodes are very
long learning could be quite slow so the
example for blackjack was an example in
which episodes are actually very very
short right they only take like maybe
one or two or three actions but they
won't take hundreds and hundreds of
actions or maybe even more than that
but if they do and you have to wait all
the way until the end of an episode
every time before you can start updating
that might be tedious
so we have to wait until an episode ends
before we can learn why do we have to do
that well because the return is not well
defined before we do right so we're
using the full return of an episode to
update towards and that means we have to
wait until the episode ends before we
even have the thing that we want to use
in our update
in addition these returns can have very
high variance in some cases especially
if episodes are long
so are there alternatives are there
other things we could use other
algorithms that maybe don't have these
downsides and of course i wouldn't be
asking this question if there wasn't an
affirmative answer
so this brings us to one of the most
important concepts in reinforcement
learning called temporal difference
learning
so i'm just going to start by reminding
you of the bellman equation that we've
talked about or diana actually talked
about at length in the previous lectures
the bellman equation relates the value
of a state with the value of the next
state or the expected value of the next
state and this is actually a definition
of the value of a policy
so the value of a policy is defined as
the expected return but turns out to be
exactly equivalent to the expected
immediate reward rt plus one
plus the discounted true value of that
policy in the next
state st plus one
we've seen that you can approximate
these values by iterating basically
turning the definition of the value into
an update so the difference here is now
that the v pi within the expectation has
been replaced with our current estimates
v k
because we're doing this in iterations
maybe across all states at the same time
so we denote this with this iteration
with some number k
and then we update our value function by
replacing maybe all of them at the same
time you could do this for all states at
the same time
with a new estimate vk plus one which is
defined as the immediate reward rt plus
one plus the discounted current estimate
of the next state value vk
and we've seen that these algorithms
actually do learn um and they they do
find the
true value of a policy
now we can see there there's on the
right hand side there's an expectation
but we could sample that so maybe we can
just plug that in and we can just say oh
maybe we just see a sample rt plus one
plus the discounted value of the next
state st plus one and then use that
well maybe you don't want to update all
the way there so instead we're going to
argue that's going to be too noisy so
instead just take a small step
so this is this now looks very similar
to the monte carlo learning algorithm
but instead of updating towards a return
full return we're going to update
towards this other target which is the
reward plus the discounted estimate for
the next state
so the change here between monte carlo
learning and this algorithm is that
we've replaced the full return with
something that uses our current value
estimates instead
note that i've written down the tabular
update here but you can extend this in
the similar way as we did for monte
carlo learning to
function approximation or actually we
did sort of bandage with states but the
bandits with states could be replaced
with monte carlo learning by simply
swapping out a reward for the return and
then similar here we could swap out that
return for this new target
so just to recap we're in the prediction
setting we're learning v pi online from
experience under a policy pi and then
the monte carlo update looks like this
the tabular monte carlo update we have
some state some value estimates maybe vn
or vt you could also call this
i'm calling it n here
i could have also used k as before
because these updates cannot actually
happen at time step t because the return
is not yet known completely at time step
t right we only know the return at the
end of the episode which might be some
data time step so instead of saying
which time step that actually is i'm
just saying oh there's some
iterate iterative procedure here and
we're updating our value function
by using the return
temporal difference learning which is
that new algorithm which we just talked
about instead uses this
this new target which just unrolls the
experience one step
and then uses our estimates to replace
the rest of the return
and this is called temporal difference
learning because the error term here is
called a temporal difference error which
looks at one step into the future and
looks at the difference in value from
what we currently think and comparing
that to one step into the future
this temporal difference error which is
simply defined as rt plus one plus the
discounted value of this state st plus
one minus our current value estimate of
the value at st
is called the temporal difference error
and we typically denote this with a
delta
so keep that in mind delta t is the
temporal difference error
and it's defined as as this
so now we can talk about these
algorithms and maybe get a bit more
intuition by thinking about them
how they work with the problem at hand
so dynamic programming works like i like
this there's some
three of possibilities here you're in
some states
and you consider all the possible
possibilities that might happen next
states here are denoted by these white
nodes actions are black smaller nodes
and then what we see here is effectively
that
sorry the dynamic programming looks at
all possible actions in this case too
and then also at all possible
transitions for each action so in this
case each action can then randomly end
up in two different states so there's
four states in total that you could end
up in after one step
and dynamic programming considers all of
these which of course requires you to
have a model that allows you to consider
all of these possibilities
conversely monte carlo learning takes a
trajectory that samples an episode all
the way until the end
this terminal state denoted here with a
green box with a t in there
and then it uses that trajectory to
construct the return and updates the
value of that state at the beginning
towards that return and of course you
could also update all of the other
states along the way towards the return
from that state
and then this new algorithm temporal
difference learning instead only uses
one sample so we see some commonalities
here with with dynamic programming in
the in the sense that we're only doing
one step
but it it does sample so it doesn't need
a model so there's some commonality with
dynamic programming in the sense we're
only doing one step deep and there's
some commonality with monte carlo
learning in the sense that we're
sampling
so we call this usage of our estimates
on the next time step bootstrapping this
is different from the use of the term
bootstrapping as the statistical
bootstrap which refers to
taking a data set and then resampling
from the data set as if it's the
underlying distribution it has nothing
to do with that in reinforcement during
bootstrapping typically refers to this
process of using a value estimate
to
update your value estimate
this is
[Music]
indicative of pulling yourself up on
your own bootstraps essentially
and it's good to to keep that in mind
that that's just the the term for doing
that and that means that under this
terminology monte carlo learning does
not bootstrap it does not use value
estimates to bootstrap upon to construct
its return its targets
but dynamic programming does and
temporal difference learning also does
these both use our current value
estimates as part of the target for
their update
and then in addition additionally we can
think about sampling where we similarly
see the monte carlo samples but now
dynamic programming does not sample it
instead uses the model and temporal
difference learning does sample
so we see we have these three algorithms
with different properties
and of course we can apply the same idea
to action values as well where we have
some
[Music]
action value function q and we simply do
exactly the same thing we did before
where we take one step
and now we also take the subsequent
action immediately a t plus one and we
can use that this to then construct the
temporal difference error exactly in the
same way as before all that i did here
is essentially replace every occurrence
of a state with a state action pair
index on the same time step
this algorithm is called sarsa
because it uses a state action reward
state and action
this name was coined by rich saturn
now in terms of property templation
learning is model free it doesn't
require knowledge of the marketization
process and it can therefore learn
directly from experience
and interestingly it can also learn from
incomplete episodes by using this
bootstrapping this means that if the
episode is really long you don't have to
wait until all of all the way in the end
of the episode before you can start
learning
and this can be quite beneficial
because then you can also learn during
the episode now the extremist case of
this that you could consider is maybe
what if your lifetime is one big episode
right what if there is no termination
and some models are indeed effectively
um
formalized as such
and then it becomes essential to be able
to learn during the episode you can't
just wait until the end of the episode
because there's only one episode
now to illustrate the differences
between these algorithms monte carlo and
temporal difference learning i'm going
to step through an example
which is called the driving home example
and this one's also due to satsang
ambarto
so how does that look
we're going to enumerate a couple of
states small number of states and
the
idea is that we start at the office and
we want to go home
now at first we're going to talk about
the columns here so the first column
shows the state we're in the second
column shows the elapsed minutes so far
the difference in each step on these
elapsed minutes you can consider your
reward so between leaving the office and
reaching the car we could say five
minutes have passed and we could call
that our reward we could basically say
oh
the reward on this transition was five
and we're just predicting here so we
don't actually care about the sign of
the reward whether it's minus five if
you would like to
maximize the the speed you might want to
minimize the minutes or something like
that we don't have to worry about that
because we're just doing predictions so
we're just saying there's a reward of
five along the way
then the column after that the third
column the predicted time to go
is our current value estimate at the
state that we're currently in so when
we're in just leaving the office we
predict it's 30 minutes in total to get
home this is the accumulation of the
rewards along the way
then just as a helpful uh mental helper
there's a final column here the
predicted total time
and this is simply a sum of the previous
two columns
this
adds together how many minutes have
already passed with the predicted time
still to go because this will give us a
feeling for how that total time is
changing
so when we're leaving the office as i
mentioned so by definition zero minutes
have passed from leaving the office and
we're predicting it's still 30 minutes
but then when we reach the car we notice
it's raining and maybe that's uh
bad because maybe that means that it
tends to be busier on the highway and
therefore even though five minutes have
already passed maybe we're also a little
bit so to get to the car
we still predicted still 35 minutes so
more than before
which means our total predicted time has
actually gone up to 40 minutes
so the way to interpret this is that the
reward along the way was five
and then the new prediction is 35
then in our next stage we exit the
highway the total amount of time elapsed
so far is 20 minutes so you can think of
this as the reward along the way was 15
minutes because it was five minutes when
we reached the car now it's 20 minutes
and from now we predict it's another 15
minutes to go
which means that the predicted total
time has actually gone down a little bit
maybe it was less busy on the highway
than we thought and things went a little
bit more smoothly than we thought
but then we exit the highway and we find
ourselves behind a truck 10 minutes
later so another 10 minutes have passed
the reward could be considered to be 10
and from this point
we we consider it another 10 minutes to
go so the total predicted time has gone
up again to 40.
then at last we arrive at the home
street
40 minutes have already passed so
another 10 minutes have passed and we
predict it's still three more minutes to
go so our total predicate time has gone
up again a little bit to 43 but our
current prediction turns out to be
completely accurate and we arrive home
after 43 minutes so another three
minutes
now what do these different algorithms
do well the monte carlo algorithm would
basically just look at the total outcome
and therefore it would then update all
of these states that you've seen so far
to take into account this new total
outcome it basically just looks at the
whole sample and it says well when you
were leaving the office you thought it
was 30 but it was actually 43. when you
reached the car five minutes had passed
you thought it was still 35 minutes more
which means our total prediction was 40.
this should have been 43
so that means that instead of predicting
35 you should have predicted 38 perhaps
run when reaching the car
and similarly when exiting the highway
or when reaching the secondary road when
we got stuck behind the truck we have to
update these predictions upwards that's
what monte carlo does
if we then look at the right hand plot
for temporal difference learning it
looks a little bit differently
when leaving the office we then reached
the car and it was raining and we
predicted it was still more time to go
there five minutes already passed and we
thought it was 35 more minutes
so when we said oh from the office it's
just 30 minutes now we're thinking when
we've reached our car no actually it's
more like 40 minutes in total so we
should update that previous state value
upwards to 40.
and you can immediately execute that you
could immediately update that state
value update
but then when we reached the car and it
was raining we thought it was 35 minutes
but then when we exited the highway 15
of those minutes had passed and then we
thought oh actually from this point
onwards it's it's not that long anymore
i can go back a slide we're here now
we were predicting from reaching the car
that it was 35 more minutes but then
when we exit the highway
we notice it's actually only 15 minutes
later than it was before and we think
it's another 15 minutes to go
that means that instead of 35 this
should have maybe been 30 instead so it
tells you to actually update that one
down
so the
purpose of showing you this is not to
say that one is right and the other one
is wrong but it's to show you the
differences between these different
algorithms how do they operate
we will see more examples later on as
well
so now we're going to compare these
algorithms a little bit more and we're
going to talk about the advantages and
disadvantages of each
so as i mentioned temporal difference
learning can learn already before
knowing the final outcome it can in fact
learn online after every step that it
has seen whereas monte carlo learning
must wait until the end of the episode
before the return is known and before it
could actually execute its update
in addition sample difference learning
can learn without the final outcome this
is useful framework for when you for
instance only have incomplete sequences
it could be the case that you have a
database of experience that you want to
learn from somehow but the database is
corrupted or is missing some data and
then thing for different temporal
difference learning could still be used
on the individual transitions that you
do have
monte carlo cannot do that and it really
needs the full return in order to be
able to do its update
in addition the ability to be able to
learn without knowing the final outcome
means that temporal difference learning
can also work in continuing environments
in which there are no episode
terminations whereas of course monte
carlo needs full episodes in order to do
its updates
finally well not fine there's one more
after this temporal difference learning
is independent of the temporal span of
the prediction so what do i mean with
that that's a whole
mouthful
i mean with this that the computation of
temporal difference learning is constant
on every time step
how many steps you want to do in an
episode does not matter in terms of the
computational complexity on each time
step for temporal difference learning so
why is that not true for monte carlo
well monte carlo needs to store
everything so to td can hear from single
transitions but monte carlo must store
all the predictions you've seen in an
episode
in order to be able to update them at
the end of the episode so that means
that the memory requirements for monster
carlo actually grow when the episode
becomes longer and longer
this is a pure computational property it
has nothing to do with the statistical
properties of these algorithms
but on the flip side temporal difference
learning needs reasonable value
estimates if these value estimates are
very bad then obviously if you're going
to construct targets using these then
maybe your updates won't be very good
and that means that actually there's a
little bit of a bias variance trade-off
going on here
the monte carlo return is actually an
unbiased estimate of the true value
this is in fact how the true value is
defined is the expectation of these
returns but the temporal difference
target is a biased estimate of course
unless you already have accurate
predictions but that's an edge case
because we don't assume that we have
them in general
now the temporal difference target does
have lower variance because the return
might depend on many random actions
transitions and rewards whereas the
temporal difference target only depends
on one random action transition and
reward
but in some cases temporal difference
learning can have irreducible lies for
instance the world might be partially
observable and the states that we're
plugging into these value estimates
might not tell us everything
that's already a problem for monte carlo
learning because it means that the
states that we're updating don't have
all the information maybe to give you a
complete accurate accurate description
and therefore your value estimates will
be a little bit off but you could
imagine that this can get worse and
indeed you can show this theoretically
as well that this can get worse if
you're additionally using these value
estimates which are a little bit off
because your state doesn't tell you
enough in constructing the target for
your update
implicitly monte carlo learning a
different way to think about this would
account for all of the latent variables
happening along the way so even though
you can't observe exactly where you are
the return itself would just
take that into account because the
return itself does depend on all of the
environment variables that you can't
maybe observe
similarly but a little bit different
the function used to approximate the
values might fit poorly and this might
also be true in the limits it might be
that your function class let's say a
linear function can't actually hold
accurate predictions for all states
if that is the case then temporal
difference learning has irreducible bias
in its target and therefore also in the
values it eventually learns
in the tabular case however both monte
carlo and temporal difference earning
will converge to the true value
estimates
we will talk more about these properties
and especially about the function
approximation part in later lectures
so now to build even more intuition
let's go into another example
called a random walk
so how does that look we have five
states it's a small example it's meant
to be an intuitive example and we have
in each of these states two actions
so we start in the middle state denoted
c here and we either go left or right
with equal probability
the initial value estimates are a half
for every state and above these
transitions you see the reward depicted
which is zero in almost all transitions
except if you take the right action from
state e then the episode terminates with
a reward of one
additionally if you take the left action
from state a the episode also terminates
with a reward of zero all of the other
transitions are worth zero
the true values happen to be 1 6 for
state a 2 6 for state b and so on and so
on until 5 6 for state e
it might be an interesting exercise for
you to go through this and to actually
prove that this is the case using
dynamic programming you could write down
the probability
of each transition and you could write
down the reward function and you could
do dynamic programming
to find these value estimates
so we put that
market transition process here on the
top and then we're going to talk about
updating the values and first we're
going to
show you
what td does
so there's
a couple of lines in this plot and these
lines correspond to our value estimates
for each of these states
after a certain number of episodes
so the line demarked with zero is fully
horizontal
and that's because we've initialized all
the state values at one half
then there's a line marked one here and
it's actually completely the same as the
line marked zero on most states except
for state a
the reason for that being that
apparently this first episode terminated
by stepping left from state a with a
reward of zero
all the other transitions
this is an undiscounted problem so on
all the other transitions
basically when we for instance maybe
steps from state b to state c
we would have seen a reward of zero
along the way and our temporal
difference error would be reward plus
next state value in this case
undiscounted there's no discount factor
or equivalently the discount factor is
one
and that next state value at c would be
one half because that's where how they
were initialized
so our target would be one-half but our
current estimate at state b would also
be one-half so the total temperature
difference error would be zero so we
wouldn't update the value of state b on
this intermediate step
but eventually we reach state a and we
take this step into the terminal state
the terminal state by definition always
has value zero so the temporal
difference error for this last
transition was actually minus a half
because it's zero reward plus a zero
next state value minus our current
estimate for state a which was a half
and then we see that we've updated the
value of state a in a tabular way
slightly down and in fact roughly 10 of
the way down or maybe even exactly 10
for the way down it started at 0.5 and
now it seems to be roughly around 0.45
so from this we can infer that the step
size parameter the learning rate was 0.1
for this td algorithm
then we can see that after say 10
episodes all of the values have by now
been updated a little bit and after 100
episodes we're very close to these true
values depicted here
as a diagonal
so this is just stepping through this
problem step by step and it can be quite
informative if you implement these
algorithms for the first time to
actually really take it take it easy and
go step by step and look at every update
to also make sure of course that there's
no errors in the implementation but also
to better understand these algorithms
and then we could run these these
different algorithms monte carlo
learning and temporal difference
learning on this problem and look at the
root mean square error so this is the
prediction error which we've now
condensed over all states so we're
looking at the total root mean squared
error across all states or the average
error
we can see here that the on the x-axis
we have the number of episodes we've
seen so far so learning proceeds when we
go from left to right
and on the y-axis we see the error of
the state predictions state value
predictions
so first i want to draw your attention
to the darkest line in both these plots
the black line this corresponds to the
lowest step size that we've tried which
is 0.01
we see that both for monte carlo
learning and for temporal difference
learning we see the smooth progression
where the error goes down as the episode
number goes up
but it's fairly slow right so the error
at um
after 100 episodes is not that low yet
and we can see it can clearly go down
farther if we can leave it running
longer
but if we wanted to learn faster so if
we wanted to only have
maybe only had 100 episodes and we had
to stop here it maybe makes sense to
pick a higher learning rate or higher
step size and we can see in that the
brown curve which corresponds to a three
times larger step size 0.03 indeed has a
lower error
not just at the end but actually at
every episode along the way
however then we start seeing a trade-off
so i'm going to draw your attention
again to the monte carlo plot and let's
now consider the brightest line
this corresponds to a fairly high step
size of 0.3 and we can see that learning
indeed is very fast at the beginning but
then almost immediately stabilizes it
doesn't go much below
0.45 roughly
and we could see that the variance is
also quite high now why is this the case
this is the case because the monte carlo
update itself has is high variance
and we cannot reduce the variance
further because we don't have a decaying
step size here which means that the
total error of this algorithm after a
couple of episodes will be
just the variants in the updates
similarly if we reduce the step size
slightly to 0.1 we see that the learning
is slightly slower at the beginning
but then goes lower the arrow does go
lower but then also stabilizes around in
this case slightly above 0.3
we can see something similar happening
for td where there's this trade-off you
can learn very quickly at the beginning
but maybe the arrow stabilizes at a
higher point but if we compare a
temporal difference learning to monte
carlo learning we can see that temporal
difference learning allows you to set
the step size higher
and also has a different trade-off and
indeed a lot of these errors are smaller
than for monte carlo
so if we look at for instance at the
midway point at 50 episodes we can see
that temporal difference learning then
prefers a step size of 0.1 if you had to
pick one constant step size whereas
monte carlo learning prefers a lower
step size of 0.03 because it has higher
variance and also the error for monte
carlo will be higher
even if we tune the step size among
these four four options
now obviously you could also extend this
and consider step size schedules which
start high and maybe go lower when you
learn more that's not the point here
necessarily i just want to show you
these properties of these algorithms
where you can kind of clearly see from
the plots that monte carlo simply has a
higher variance than temporal difference
earning and in this case that leads to
higher errors for any constant step size
essentially if you want to tune over on
your constant step sizes
okay
now we're going to look even more in
depth at these properties of these
algorithms by considering batch updating
so the
we know that tabular monte carlo and
temporal difference learning do converge
to the true value estimates so if we
store all of the values separately in
the table we can update all of them
independently to eventually become
accurate
under the conditions that your
experience goes to infinity and your
step size decays slowly to towards zero
but what about finite experience of
course in practice we won't actually
have infinite experience we're going to
learn for some time it might be a long
time but it won't be infinitely long and
we won't actually decay our step size
all the way to zero perhaps
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to consider a fixed batch of
experience and specifically we're going
to consider having collected k different
episodes
and each of these episodes will consist
of a number of steps so these number of
steps per episode can differ but
they might all have a
large or small number of steps and then
we're going to repeat each sample from
these episodes and apply either monte
carlo learning or temporal difference
learning
it says here td0 reasons for calling
this algorithm td0 will become clear
later but this is just the standard
temporal difference learning algorithm
that we discussed so far
you can view this as basically similar
to sampling from an empirical model
where we talked about in the dynamic
programming lecture having a model and
then being able to
use that to learn
in this case you could also consider
having the data set which in some sense
defines frequencies of observed
frequencies of transitions which is
similar to having a model but it's an
empirical model and it won't exactly fit
with the real
underlying model because you only have a
finite amount of experience
and now we're going to apply this idea
of batch learning to a specific small
example in which we only have two states
where the purpose is for us to be able
to reason through this all
all the way
so the two states let's just call them a
and b
there's not going to be any discounting
and let's say we have eight episodes of
experience
here each line below denotes exactly one
episode
so one of these episodes starts
in a state a and then gets a reward of
zero then proceeds to a state b and then
another reward of zero and then the
episode terminates
the next episode on the next line we
started in state b instead of a and then
we got a reward of one and terminated
that happens more often so six out of
these eight episodes are
of that form where we start in b and
then terminate with a reward of one and
then we also have one episode that did
start in b as well but it terminated
with a reward of zero
now i want you to think about
maybe even without thinking about these
algorithms at all i want you to think
about what are the values of states a
and b what do you think these values
should be
if this is all the information that you
have you have absolutely no information
apart from
this data set
so i encourage you to pause the video
perhaps and think about this for a
little bit and then i'm just going to
proceed and going to tell you what
i think are maybe plausible values
so
it could be that you came up with
maybe even more than one answer or it
could be that some of you came up with
one answer and some came up with a
different answer so let me motivate two
different answers here
first let me start with state b maybe
that one's somewhat obvious
so from state b we've seen eight
episodes that were ever in state b and
six out of eight times we saw a plus one
and two out of eight times we saw zero
so maybe the appropriate value for state
b is 0.75
we've also seen one episode that was in
state a and in that episode we got a
total return of zero
so one could reasonably say maybe the
value of state a is always zero or at
least that maybe is our best guess that
we could do
now when i say that some of you might
actually object and say no no no that's
not the right way to think about this
the right way to think about this is
that whenever you were in state a sure
it only happened once but like whenever
you were in state a you transitioned to
state b and there was a reward of zero
along the way
this implies that state a and b must
have exactly the same value
that is also a reasonable argument but
that means that the value of state a
would be 0.75 which is quite different
from zero
if you were using that second line of
reasoning effectively what you're
arguing for is that the underlying model
maybe looks like this that maybe this is
the suitable way to think about this a
goes to b a hundred percent of the time
as far as we know and then b gets plus
175 percent of the time and zero 25 at
the time
so what is the right answer here well
that's actually a little bit unclear and
i'm going to explain why both these
answers are actually in some way
reasonable
so monte carlo learning
converges to the best mean square fit
for the observed returns so you can
write this as follows where we sum over
the episodes k
from one to big k and then within each
episode we look at all the time steps
from one to
t k big t k for that episode
and then we could look at all of the
returns that you've seen and compare
that to our current value estimates and
then we could say we want to minimize
the squared error between these returns
and that we've observed and these value
estimates and that indeed sounds like a
very reasonable approach right we're
just minimizing the difference between
the returns we have seen and the value
estimates that we have
in the example that we've just seen this
would imply that the value of state a is
zero because the only return we've ever
seen in state a was zero
instead temporal difference learning
converts to the solution of the max
likelihood markov model given the data
that's what we saw on the previous slide
this is the most likely model given the
data that we've seen so far and then
temporal difference learning turns out
finds that solution that corresponds to
this model so if you agree with that
approach if you say well that's what you
should be estimating and then you should
be solving that that's what temporal
difference learning does
so this would be the solution of the
empirical markov decision process
assuming that the empirical data you've
seen is actually the true data
so in the example this is what gives you
the same estimate for both states a and
b
now you might find one better than the
other but why would you take one or the
other this actually is a little bit of a
subtle argument
and turns out you can think about it as
follows where temporal difference
learning exploits the mark of property
and this means this can help learning in
fully observable environments
what i mean with that is that the
assumption essentially when we built
that model that empirical model in the
previous example
the assumption there is that if you're
in state b
then it doesn't matter that you were in
state a before we can just estimate the
value of state b separately
and
this will tell us all that will happen
from state b onwards
that's basically making an assumption
that state b is markovian
instead you could also say
and this is what monte carlo exploits
well what if we don't assume that then
we could say well whenever we were in
state a it turns out that our second
reward was zero and this could be
related it could be that whenever we are
in state a that we already know that all
of the rewards in the future are going
to be zero
if we then reach state b
it might be that this is still true but
we just can't see it it's a latent
variable it's a hidden variable this
means that the world is not fully
observable
if that were true for the problem that
we were in that would be the better
estimate perhaps
and indeed learning with monte carlo can
help in partially observable
environments because it makes less of an
assumption that the states are
useful to construct your value estimates
so we mentioned this before so in some
sense you can view this example with
this two-state batch learning as an
example of
this difference in terms of how they
deal with fully observed versus sparsely
observed environments
important to note is that with finite
data and also with function
approximation the solutions even in the
limits might differ between temporal
difference learning and monte carlo
these are two different statements we
saw just we've seen it just now for
finite data it's also true for function
approximation i haven't actually shown
you that but we'll get back to that in
later lectures
so now of course maybe a natural
question is can we maybe get the best of
both
first i'm just going to show you a
unified view where we put dynamic
programming in the top left
and the reason why it's there is that
left
corresponds here to shadow updates where
we just look one step into the future
the top versus bottom in the top we we
look at mechanisms that look full breath
of course in order to do that you do
need to have access to the model
so that means that for instance if we
look both
full breadth and full depth this would
give you exhaustive search
i'm just showing that to complement the
other approaches i'm not saying that's
an algorithm that you should be using
it's computationally quite expensive and
of course you also need a model
but it clearly
fits in the figure in terms of like
comparing breadth and depth of these
algorithms
then if we go down we go to these
algorithms that only look at one
trajectory and these can be used when we
only can sample when we only deal with
interaction so we see temporal
difference learning in the top sorry the
bottom left
and monte carlo in the bottom right
where we can think now about temporal
difference learning as
having a breadth of one but also only a
depth of one so we can just take one
step in the world and we can use that to
update a valley estimate
whereas monte carlo
makes a very deep update it rolls
forward all the way until the end of the
episode and uses that full trajectory to
then update its value estimates
now as discussed temple difference
learning uses value estimates which
might be inaccurate and in addition to
that which we haven't quite uh talked
about so much yet the information can
propagate quite slowly i'll show you an
example of this in a moment
this means that if we see a reward that
is quite useful like it's a surprising
reward tempo difference learning will by
its nature only update the state value
immediately immediately in front of it
if in that episode you never reach that
state again that means that all of the
other state values don't learn about
this reward
whereas monte carlo would update all of
the previous states that you visited in
that episode eventually to learn about
this new reward
so that means that temporal difference
learning has a problem in the sense that
information can propagate quite slowly
backwards and therefore the credit
assignment could be quite slow
now
monte carlo learning does propagate
information faster as i just said if you
do see your surprising reward monte
carlo learning will at the end of the
episode tell all the previous states
about that but of course the updates are
noisier and it has all the other
properties that we talked about before
now we can actually go in between these
and one way to do that is as follows
instead of looking exactly one step
ahead as temporal difference learning
does we could consider looking two steps
ahead or three steps or generically end
steps ahead
then we could consider monte carlo
learning to be at the other end of
other extreme essentially where monte
carlo looks infinitely far into the
future up until the end of the episode
written in equations you could write
that as follows where maybe we can
introduce new notation
where we use
superscript with brackets so superscript
since g with one between brackets is now
a one step return
which takes exactly one step in the
world rt plus one and then bootstraps at
our current value estimates of sd one
so one step
a one step return corresponds exactly to
temporal difference learning as we
defined it before
an infinite step return shown in the
bottom here would correspond to monte
carlo learning because if you take
infinite steps you always will reach the
end of the episode before you choose to
bootstrap
but then in between we could consider
for instance a two-step approach which
takes not just one reward but takes two
rewards into account and then bootstraps
on the value of the state at time step t
plus 2.
in general we can say the n step return
so oftentimes i say multi-step returns
here in the tight title of the slide but
colloquially people often refer to these
mechanisms as air using n-step returns
and it's defined by simply taking n
rewards into account and then
appropriately discounting them
please note that the last reward reward
at t plus n is discounted only n minus
one times which is consistent with the
one step approach
but the value estimate is then
discounted n times
and then we can just use this in our
updates
so does that mean that we have to wait a
little bit of time before we can
actually execute this update and we do
have to store some estimates or states
along the way but only as many as we
want so if we have a 10 step return we
have to wait 10 steps every time before
we can update a state value
and we have to store the ten states
along the way every time in some
something of a buffer so it has these
intermediate properties that are both
statistically and computationally a
little bit between a temporal difference
ordering on one extreme and monte carlo
learning on the other extreme
so now i'm going to show you some
examples to make that a bit more
concrete
first we're going to talk about an
example to illustrate essentially
this property that td doesn't propagate
information for backwards and for that
we're going to use sarsa i'm going to
remind you that sarsa is simply temporal
difference learning for state action
values
so if we look on the left we see a
specific path that was taken we started
apparently over here then we went right
right up right up and so on
in the end we reached the goal
if we would then do one step td in this
case one step sarsa we would only update
the state action value for the action
that led immediately to the goal this is
of course assuming that all of the other
intermediate steps have no information
maybe the rewards are zero maybe your
current state estimates are also zero
and maybe you only get a plus one when
you reach the goal
if we could then instead consider a
10-step
update it would actually update all of
these state values appropriately
discounted along the way
so it would propagate the information
much further back and then if we
consider the next episode this could be
beneficial because in the next episode
it could be that you start maybe here
again and then if you only did one step
td or sarsa in this case it could be
that you just meander around without
learning anything new for a long time
whereas if you would have done a 10 step
return at least you're more likely to
more quickly bump into one of these
updated state values and then
information could start propagating
backwards to the beginning where you
start
so we can apply this to a random walk
just to see and get a bit of more of
intuition so we see the same random walk
that we talked about before here at the
top but now let's consider giving it 19
states rather than five but otherwise
it's the same there's a starting state
in the middle there's a plus one reward
on one end and there's a zero on the
other end
and then we can apply these n-step-r
algorithms
and see how they fare so what you see
here on the slide is something called a
parameter plot because on the x-axis we
have a parameter in this case the step
size parameter and on the y-axis we see
the root mean squared error over the
first 10 episodes so we're not looking
at infinite experience here we're just
looking at a finite amount of experience
and then we see
how do these algorithms fare if you then
look at all of these different step
sizes
so for instance let's look at n is one n
is one i remind you corresponds exactly
to the normal temporal difference
learning algorithm that we discussed
before
we see that the best performance or the
lowest error if we only care about the
first 10 episodes and we have to pick a
constant step size is for a step size
around maybe 0.8
if you set it higher or lower the error
is a little bit worse
this has been averaged over multiple
iterations so this is why these curves
look so smooth this is of course a
fairly small problem so you could run
this quite quite often to get very good
insights on what's happening very
precise insights i should maybe say
and what we notice here is if n is two
so we consider a two-step approach we
see that if the step size is really high
if it's one that it actually does a
little bit worse and this is because the
variance is in some sense higher
but you can actually tune your step size
around in this case 0.6 to get lower
arrows than where possible with the one
step approach over the first 10 episodes
then taking n is 4 is maybe even a
little bit better but notice again that
the preferred action sorry the preferred
step size parameter is again a little
bit lower this is because if we increase
n as we do here
the variance goes up more and more and
more
and that implies that we need a lower
and lower step size to make sure that we
don't have updates that have too high
variance which would make our error
higher
then if we go all the way up here we see
a line that is marked with the number
512
that is a 512 step temporal difference
learning algorithm which in this case is
essentially monte carlo because there
are very the probability of having an
episode that is more than 512 steps long
is very small
and we can also see that by the fact
that the 256
step tempo difference earning algorithm
is actually quite similar because both
of those are already quite similar to
the full monte carlo algorithm
for these algorithms we see two things
first they prefer very small step sizes
of
much much smaller than temporal
difference learning the one september
difference learning
and in addition even if you tune the
constant step size very well the error
will still be quite small
quite high sorry and if you set the step
size too high the arrow will be much
much higher they go off
out of the plot here
so we clearly see a trade-off a bias
variance trade-off here essentially
where an intermediate value of n helps
us learn faster and helps us get lower
error in the first over the first 10
episodes
for a well-tuned step size parameter
and the best values are not the extremes
so it's not n this is one and it's also
not n is infinity so it's not td it's
not monte carlo but it's some
intermediate n-step td algorithm
okay
so make sure you understood that last
bit because now we're going to go on to
a next very related bit though
which is on multi mixed multi-step
returns
so
we've just talked about n-step returns
so as i said make sure you understood
that part before continuing here and
these n-step returns they bootstrap
after n steps on a state value st plus n
one way to write down these returns is
almost recursively they don't quite
recurse but you could look at them
these returns as doing the following
where if you have an n step return you
take one step rt plus one
and then you add an n minus one step
return
right so every step you lose one step
until you only have one step left and
the one step return will then bootstrap
on your state value
so why am i writing it like this because
you can then look at these different
cases and we could basically say well
on some of these steps we fully continue
with the random sample with the
trajectory whereas on other steps we
fully stop we just say okay that's
enough bootstrap here
and now i'm going to argue well you
could do that but you don't have to do
that instead there's a different thing
which you could do which is to say you
could bootstrap a little bit
for instance you could have a parameter
which we're going to call labda
so we're going to take one step as
always and then we're going to take the
discount factor but then instead of
either continuing or bootstrapping fully
we say let's bootstrap a little bit
so this is a linear interpolation
between our estimated matrix value and
the rest of that labda return as we call
it
this is defined recursively so this lab
of return is at the next time step for
the same lab so this thing will also
take one step
and then again bootstrap a little bit
before continuing and then again it
would take one step and then again boots
up a little bit before continuing even
farther
turns out if you do the math this is
exactly equivalent to a weighted sum
of n step returns
in fact of all of the n step returns
from one to infinity
these weights do sum to one so it's a
proper weighted average of these and we
can note by just stepping through a few
examples if n is one then this quantity
here goes away this is just one so the
the one step return will be weighted
exactly with a weight of one minus
lambda then the two-step return will be
weighted but by a weight of lab that
time for a minus laplace so slightly
less
typically labda is a it's a number
between zero and one and typically it's
a number that is maybe closer to one
than to zero
but if we set loudness to say a half for
simplicity that would mean that our lab
of return would
basically take a one-step return with
weights a half a two-step return with
weight a quarter a three-step return
with weight one-eighth and so on and so
on
then we can consider these special cases
where if labda is zero we can say that
see that this term would completely
disappear and this term would just get
weight one that means that la da zero
corresponds exactly to the standard td
algorithm
whereas if we consider the case where
lab days one then the recursion is full
we just have one reward plus discounted
next
lab the return but if lab day is one
this would also just take the full next
reward and ends one so that would be
exactly the same as monte carlo
so we can see we've have the same
extremes as before
for the n-step returns where lab is zero
now corresponds to temporal difference
learning one-step temporal difference
learning and lab as one corresponds to
full monte carlo this is why on a
previous slide you saw td0 pop up that
was actually referring exactly to this
algorithm where we say there's a more
generic algorithm called td labda but
you can set lablet to zero and then you
have your one step td algorithm
we can compare these to these n step
approaches and we here we plot them side
by side for that same
multi-step
random walk
and we see some commonalities first let
me draw your attention to lab that is
zero which is exactly the same curve as
for n is one this is true by definition
because this is these are both the one
set td algorithm
and then similarly we can see for lab is
one i promise you that was exactly monte
carlo and we can indeed see that that's
very similar to the curve here for the
512 and also for the 256
step td algorithms
intermediately the curves look slightly
different you can see that these this
curve for instance
branches are slightly differently than
that one and they also don't exactly
correspond to each other because these
n-step approaches always choose exactly
one time step in which the bootstrap
whereas the labda approaches they
bootstrap a little bit on multiple
timestamps
but you can see the curves actually look
somewhat similar and there's a rule of
thumb that you can use to think about
how these relate to each other maybe you
think all these n-step approaches i find
a little bit more intuitive because i
can reason about two steps but i find it
harder to reason about this lab that
well one way to think about this is that
there's a rough correspondence where we
can think of one divided by one minus
lambda as roughly being the horizon of
the lablet return so for instance if we
set labla to be 0.9
then this would be this one minus lab
that would be 0.1 and then 1 divided by
0.1 would simply be 10. so we could say
that louder 0.9 roughly corresponds to
an n-step of 10 and we can see that
corresponds here in the plot where we
can see that lab.0.8 which would
correspond to a 5-step method is indeed
quite similar to this 4-step method over
here and 0.9 which corresponds to
roughly 10 steps is indeed quite similar
to this eight-step
temporal difference learning method here
and they're even colored the same way
that maybe makes it a little bit clearer
this corresponds as well
they're slightly different you could
look for instance at the lab.4 which is
presumably quite similar to lab.5 which
would correspond to this two-step
approach and especially for higher
learning rates they do look a little bit
different
but there is a rough correspondence and
this is one way to think about these
other algorithms
and now we're going to talk about some
benefits so we've already alluded to
this
so multi-step returns have benefits from
both temporal difference learning and
monte carlo
and the reason to consider them is that
bootstrapping can have issues with bias
so one step td is not always great and
monte carlo can have issues with
variance and typically we can think
about intermediate values as being
somewhat good because they trade off
bias and variants in an appropriate way
in addition i talked about this
information propagation which has a
similar flavor to it so intermediate
values what do i mean with that well
typically we see things like n is 5 or n
is 10 or something as a form or a lab.9
is somehow always magically a good value
so these are intermediate values that
tend to work quite well in practice
okay
now make sure that you understood all of
the things i was talking about before
before continuing to the next section in
addition i want to
basically attend you to the fact that
the next part is uh more advanced
and you don't need it to continue with
the rest of the lectures so you could
also pause here and maybe return to this
later if you wish
um
or you could just continue now of course
because it's quite related to the things
we were talking about before but i just
wanted to draw your attention to the
fact that this is going to be
in some sense a little bit orthogonal to
some of the things that we'll be
discussing later
okay so having said that let's continue
so we talked a little bit before about
this dependence on the temporal span of
the predictions
and maybe you've already realized this
these multi-step approaches these mixed
multi-step approaches especially that we
talked about are actually not
independent of spam
which means that similar to monte carlo
you actually have to wait all the way
until the end of the episode before you
know your labor return
right the lab that trades off
statistical properties of the updates
but it still has the same computational
update that you actually can only
construct your full ladder return when
you've reached the end of the episode
now that doesn't seem very desirable and
indeed you might also sometimes want to
do monte carlo learning and then that
might also not be desirable
and conversely temporal difference
earning can update immediately and is
independent of the span of the
predictions
so
before maybe you took this to be an
argument that we should be using
temporal difference learning but here
i'm going to make a different argument
and we're going to ask can we get the
best of both worlds can we use these
mixed multi-step returns or
like other flavors of that including
maybe even monte carlo but with an
algorithm that doesn't have
computational requirements that grow
indefinitely
during the episode
and turns out of course i wouldn't be
asking this question if it wasn't the
case so i'm going to explain to you how
that works
for concreteness let's recall linear
function approximation where we have a
value function that is a linear function
so we have a value function defined as
an inner product of a weight vector w
with some features x
and then monte carlo and temporal
difference learning the update to the
weights can be written as follows for
monte carlo learning it's a step size
times your return minus current
estimates times features and for tempo
difference learning is your step size
times your tempo difference error thanks
for features
and then for monte carlo learning we're
going to talk about monte carlo first
for a bit
we can update all states in an episode
at once
so
this is typical because you have to wait
for
the end of the episode for all states
anyway to know the return so it's quite
typical for monte carlo loading to then
just update all of them at once in one
big batch
here we're going to use t
from 0 to big t or in this case big t
minus 1 to enumerate all of the time
steps in this specific episode so we're
restarting the time to count from zero
in every episode essentially
and now
oh yeah first i just want to record a
tabular just a special case where the x
vector
is just a one-half vector
and now i'm going to argue
that we can look at these individual
updates here so here we have an update
on every time step
and we just summon over time steps i'm
going to argue that you can define and
update as follows
i'm going to prove this in a moment but
first i'm just going to give you the
update to build some intuition
this update
is a very simple update that takes an
alpha step size parameter times your one
step td error this is not your monte
carlo return this is the one step td
error times some vector e
this e is called an eligibility trace
and it's defined recursively by taking
the previous trace
decaying it according to gamma and
ladder and then adding our current
feature vector or more generally your
gradient x t
note special case if lab is zero we do
indeed get one step tbtd back
so there's a choice here whether you
want to do online td which means you
update during the episode you could also
consider for conceptual simplicity you
consider offline td where you still just
accumulate
these weight updates until the end of
the episode
but then this algorithm would just be td
for label a0
the intuition here is we're basically
storing a vector that calls all of the
eligibilities of past states for the
current temporal difference error
and then we're going to add add that to
our update to the weights so when ladder
is not zero we have this kind of trace
that goes into the past it's similar to
momentum but it serves a slightly
different purpose here which will hold
recursively this e t minus one will
therefore hold the x t minus one the
features from the previous state
and
but property decayed and also x t minus
two and so on and so on each decade even
more
so this is kind of magical i haven't yet
shown you why it works or how it works
but this means that if this works we can
update all of the past states to account
for the new temporal difference error
with a single update we don't need to
re-recompute their values we don't need
to store them so this would be an
algorithm if it works that will be
independent of the temporal span of the
predictions we don't need to store
all of the individual features x t x t
minus 1 x t minus 2 and so on and so on
instead we just merge them together by
adding them into this vector and we only
have to store that vector
this idea does extend to function
approximation i mean this is already the
linear function approximation case but
the so in general xt does not have to be
one hot but it can actually also be a
gradient of your value function for the
nonlinear case
how does that look well here we're just
going to show that kind of intuitively
again so there's a markov decision
process here in which we only ever step
down or to the right in the end we reach
some goal states from which we get a
reward of plus one and this then we
transition all the way back
to the top
so the trajectory here will be somewhat
random the true values are there's
discounting so the true values are
larger the closer we are to that goal if
we then imagine doing only one episode
td0 would only update the last state so
the state in which we saw that one
reward
td labda would instead update all of the
state values along the way
less and less so with labda this is true
if you do the version that we had before
with the louder return but turns out the
exact same thing is also true if you use
these editability traces
and the way to think about that is that
at some point we see this temporal
difference error where we finally see
this reward of plus one that we've never
seen before
and then we multiply that in with all of
these taking into account all of these
previous features that we've seen in
this case it's tabular so all of the
features are one hall but so basically
we're storing we're storing all of the
states in this vector and we're updating
it in one go
now i'm going to show you how that works
and why it works so we're going to
consider monte carlo first and later
i'll put the lab.parameter back in
so we're just going to take the monte
carlo error and we're first going to
rewrite this as a sum of temporal
difference error
so to start let's first write it out one
step
so we get our first step our reward t
plus one and then our discounted next
return next step return
and we're just taking along the minus v
parts from uh from the left hand side
now this already looks similar to
temporal difference error but it's not
so for a temporal difference error we
should bootstrap so what we can do is we
can just add that in so we basically add
gamma times v
[Music]
of the next state in and then we also
have to subtract it so we're basically
adding zero
but this allows us to write this as a
temporal difference error plus a
different term
and this term notice that this is
exactly the same term as before but just
at the next time step so now there's a t
plus one rather than a t
so then we can write this as an
immediate simple difference error plus a
discounted monte carlo error at the next
time step
of course we can repeat this so the
monte carlo error at the next time set
will just be the td error at the next
time step plus the discount the monte
carlo error at the time step after that
so we repeat this over and over again
and we notice that we can write
excuse me we can write the total monte
carlo error as a sum of temporal
difference error of one step temporal
different error
and i'm just going to put this basically
aside for now and i'm going to use this
on the next slide
so now we're going to go back to this
total update so at the end of the
episode we're going to update all of our
weights
according to all of these monte carlo
returns that we've seen constructed so
far which we've only were able to
construct at the end of the episode
now i'm going to plug in this thing that
we derived in the previous time step
sorry the previous slide where we're
replacing this monte carlo error with
this summation over time of temporal
difference errors
note that the summation only starts at
time step t which is the time step from
which the monte carlo return also starts
and now we're going to use a generic
property of double sums we have an outer
sum that sums from t 0 to t minus 1 to
big t minus one and an inner sum that
starts at this variable t and then
continues to the same endpoint
turns out if you have a double summation
like this where the inner index depends
or the starting point of the inner index
depends on the outer index you can turn
them around and you could first sum over
all of the outer indexes instead and
then sum over the what used to be the
outer index sorry so now we're summing
over all of the what used to be the
inner index k
and then we we sum off what used to be
the outer in x t but only up to k
so instead of starting at t
starting k at t and then going up
we do all of the k but then we only do
the t up to k this turns out to be
exactly equivalent it's a generic
property of these double sums and i'll
show you this intuitively in a moment as
well
and then we notice that the temporal
difference error
delta k does not depend on this variable
of the inner sum it doesn't depend on t
so we can pull that out and then we just
say oh this rest thing that we have here
this summation from t is zero to to k
it's a discounted sum of feature vectors
and we give that an a we just call that
e
where we notice that e actually only
depends on time steps on time step k and
before
so this means we can write this down as
follows where we now
swap k for t because we only have one
variable that we're summing over now so
we can just rename k to t and that means
that the original summation
can be rewritten in this form so
originally we had for every state
we had this update of a return looking
into the future right this is why we had
to wait all the way until the end of the
episode because we have to wait for gt
to be completely defined
and we swap this around to a summation
where we have our
same step size and our temporal
difference error delta t and then this
weight vector which kind of looks into
the past it stores all of the feature
vectors that we've seen in previous
states
and we just kind of went through this
mechanically right we haven't actually
taken any magical steps you can just do
this step by step of course coming up
with this derivation is it may be a
different matter but you can now follow
this step by step and see that this is
indeed true
so that means that our total update can
be written as this where this
eligibility trace vector was defined as
the summation of the time step t
of our discounted
feature vectors
this we can also inspect a little bit
more and we can for instance pull off
the last time step which is just xt
note that when j is equal to t then this
discounting goes away because it would
just be your discount to the power 0
which is 1. so we get this term that we
pull off and then the summations only to
t minus 1 rather than enter t
now we can also pull off one discount
factor exactly one so there will be now
a minus one here and then we can notice
that here
e t was defined of a summation of
something that goes to t and inside
there's a t and now we have something
that only sums up the t minus one and
inside as a t minus one but otherwise
it's exactly the same so this thing must
be by definition e t minus one
which means we can write this
recursively this summation as a
discounted previous e t minus one plus
the current xt
and then et we're going to call that an
eligibility trace
so the intuition here is that every step
it decays according to the discount and
then the current feature is added
because we're doing full monte carlo so
discount here is appropriate for
propagating information backwards
because you shouldn't propagate the
information more than it is used in
these monte carlo returns which came in
earlier states and that should take into
account the discounting
so then summarizing we have this
immediate kind of like update for every
time step which is completely well
defined on time step t we have all these
quantities available for us at time step
t
then the monte carlo update would sum
all of these deltas over all of the time
steps in the episode and then apply them
this is the offline algorithm so in this
case even though we can compute these
things along the way we can now compute
this sum incrementally as we go so we
don't have growing memory requirements
but then in this specific algorithm
we're still applying them at the end
of course you might not already be
thinking but that feels unnecessary
can't we just apply them during the
episode
and yes indeed you can so this is indeed
an interesting extension that you can
now start doing something that would be
equivalent to monte carlo if you would
wait all the way until the end of the
episode and only then apply these
differences
but you could already start learning
journey during the episode so we haven't
just reached an algorithm that has the
property that is independent of span
which is a computational property but
we've actually also arrived at an
algorithm which is now able to update
its predictions during long episodes
even though we started with the monte
carlo
algorithm
the intuition of this update is that the
same temporal difference error shows up
in multiple monte carlo errors in fact
in all of the monte carlo errors for
states that happened before this time
step
and then what we do is basically we
group all of these states together and
apply this in one update
you can't always do that but you can do
that here
now i'm going to look at that that
double summation thing a little bit and
show you why that works
and for doing that we're going to
concretely consider an episode with four
steps
so it says delta v here it should have
written its delta w there so we've noted
before that delta w for an episode is
just the summation of all the monte
carlo errors with their feature vectors
and we've also noted that we can write
each of these as a summation of
appropriately discounted temporal
difference errors multiplied with that
same feature because we're just pulling
off out this part the
monte carlo error
and then essentially all that we're
doing is instead of summing across these
rows we're going to sum across the
columns which will look
like this
where basically we notice that across
the columns
the the temporary difference error is
always the same
so instead we're going to merge all of
these appropriately discounted state
feature vectors and we're going to merge
it into a vector called the editability
trace
feel free to step through that of course
much more slowly than i'm doing right
now
and then we can do mixed multi-step
returns as well by putting the lab the
parameter back in
how that works is we had our mixed
multi-step return g labda and it turns
out if you write this as a sum of
temporal difference error
you can go through that yourself in a
similar way that we did the monte carlo
returns it turns out you get this
summation
which no longer
now no longer just says your discount
factor but it has a quantity ladder
times gamma
otherwise it's exactly the same thing so
it turns out we can write these labdad
returns as also a summation of one step
temporal difference error
but with gamma times lambda where we had
gamma before and that means if we go
through all of those steps again that we
did before for the monte carlo case we
get exactly the same algorithm except
that the temp that the eligibility trace
now has a trace decay gamma times lambda
rather than just gamma
so you feel free to go through all of
that yourself to convince yourself that
this is actually the case and that means
that we can then implement this
algorithm
and actually also maybe apply these
updates online as we go
this is called an accumulating trace
because every time we add this x there
it turns out in the literature there's a
couple of other traces as well which i
won't cover
now
but they are mentioned in french and
susan lombardo in the book
the equivalences here between the monte
carlo updates
and then doing this with these traces is
only completely exact if we update
offline that means we wait we store all
of the weight updates we can add them
together already but we don't actually
change our weight yet
but there are also trace algorithms that
work and are exactly equivalent in some
sense for online updating
so these traces look slightly
differently as i mentioned i won't go
into that but i just wanted to make you
aware that they exist
okay that brings us to the end of this
lecture
in the next lecture we will be talking
about applying these ideas to control to
optimize our policy
thank you for paying attention